hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no clips so here is someone
on The View saying something most likely
racist bigoted homophobic transphobic or
just generally stupid
oh my God this is a party that says we
believe in parents rights you're telling
me that as a parent I don't I'm not
smart enough to decide if my child and I
need to have gender affirming our
doctors are not involved what is going
so I can't Mike I can't decide what my
kid reads I can't decide for my child
what my child says is going on you're
telling me your beliefs your and they
keep saying it and I keep saying what
Bible are you reading yeah because God
was really clear very soon